insects spiders and other creepy
crawlies a hundred times larger than in
real life for some a nightmare but not
for the creator of these replicas
Ullaeus stirs she lives in Hamburg and
started out as a costume designer but
more than 15 years ago she turned her
professional gaze from the stars on the
stage to the teeming world below I've
always been interested in insects I grew
up in the country and played outdoors
all the time the tiny creatures
fascinated me Julian Gordon I loved to
sit in front of ant hills and observe
the goings on all the sex and crime he
was gripping that's how it developed on
us in figured Julia stirrers has found a
niche market providing museums with
replicas of insects a rarity till she
burst onto the scene she uses real
physical critters as models as well as
photos often provided by the zoological
Institute of Hamburg University her
replicas are true to life accurate in
their details currently she's working on
an Asian Bush mosquito every animal has
its distinctive attributes they
absolutely have to be there in any
replica for example the number of
bristles on a certain part of the body
in the case of the Asian Bush mosquito
it's the white stripes on the legs and
abdomen I can't make anything up in
terms of form or color I have to stick
to the facts
museums all over Europe are lining up
for her replicas and recently Stuart's
received an order from Canada eight of
her masterpieces are now on show at the
Natural History Museum in Bielefeld it's
an opportunity for people to get to know
insects in a new way in a hunting can he
donphan if everybody knows elephants and
they're great for PR to common housefly
I don't think so but when you see
insects close up and really big and in
totally accurate replicas as if you're
looking through a microscope then you
see just how fantastic they are and we
could not survive without insects entire
ecosystems would soon collapse without
them it takes stirs between three and
six months to make one replica the Asian
Bush mosquito is for a museum in Munster
first she fashions models of the various
body parts and makes molds around them
with which to make the components of the
final product I make the molds out of
silicon then I pour in plastic to make
the parts when they harden they look
like this that's the mosquitos abdomen
it's the basis for all the further
stages then comes all the careful
detailed work stirrers has to find the
right bristles or hair I use a lot of
elk hair Elks have many different kinds
of hair from very fine - very bristly so
they're suitable for many different
species raindeers good - I've also used
goat and dog hair
each piece no matter how tiny has to be
glued in place by hand
stir star jizz between 8 and 25000 euros
for her replicas she wants people to
appreciate that insects are not just
pasts but actually important and lovely
[Music]
since I started paying so much attention
to insects I've learned how incredibly
varied they are and how skilled they are
at surviving they're so clever and they
can do so much it's amazing plus they're
totally beautiful even mosquitos thanks
to Ullaeus Ursus tireless efforts and
artistry we can now meet her beloved
creepy crawlies face-to-face
you